foreign
sent me something that they wanted my
take on because it stretched the bounds
of credulity as far as they were
concerned and they wanted to know
whether or not it looked different from
from my perspective uh Zach can you put
up that uh tweet I sent you many people
have been asking me how I got my
orchiditis despite being unvaccinated
two days after spending time with a
friend who had just received the vaccine
my heart began to have severe
irregularities and took me a year to
recover vaccine shedding is a valid
concern and this is from an account uh
Dr Simon godek who is a Brazilian he is
a he has a PHD it's not a medical degree
uh he's a technologist of some kind and
the question here is he's reporting this
is not the funniest a friend of his
friend forwarded this tweet and said
basically should I take this seriously
and I thought that this was an excellent
place to take our evolving model for a
spin right is this person reporting
something that we all ought to be
concerned about that is to say a
recently vaccinated person shedding
something presumably uh pseudo-iridine
stabilized mrnas causing
myocarditis even though one was not
vaccinated
alarming if true
so I want to tell you a little bit about
the evolution of my understanding of the
shedding question so the shedding the
issue of shedding has been discussed for
a very long period of time since the
beginning of the vaccination campaign
people have reported yeah
um people have reported all kinds of
anecdotal stuff
now my understanding and I think it's
your understanding as well is that
there's something very unlikely about
the idea of being in close proximity to
a vaccinated person and being
importantly affected by something shed
by them just just just at the like
density dependence level of analysis
there's just not it doesn't seem like
there's enough of it well it seems like
there can't be enough of it for the
following reason
if a person is given the inoculation
they get a huge dose
hundreds of millions of particles
the amount that they could shed into the
environment would be a tiny fraction of
that so the point is if the stuff that a
person sheds into the environment is
itself
um
lethal right if this was you know
polonium-like or something then the
point is the dose that they got
themselves would have been so immense
that you would expect nobody to survive
it right so the point is one if you take
a standard model of
um
of
just simply dosages and materials this
does not sound like a familiar material
that a person could get a huge amount of
it injected into them and shed enough of
it to cause a pathology in an adjacent
person right
um so anyway that was my initial doubt
I the day I met Robert Malone Robert
Malone came to our house to our studio
to do Dark Horse which is where I met
him yep instantly liked the guy right
instantly like the guy because he has
the same love of biology that you and I
do and the same interest in finding
somebody else who knows something about
the topic and playing back and forth
just volleying non-competitive very
interested in talking about anything you
might raise it doesn't show up with the
diploma going like I stopped learning
back in whenever was I graduated and I'm
not I'm read only now right like good
scientists are never read only right and
you know also very much to his credit
any time that uh in my case something I
said to him challenged what he had
previously thought he would admit in
real time oh hadn't thought of it that
way that's interesting it might be such
and such and so and so anyway so I asked
him after the podcast I said look I've
been hearing a lot about this shedding
stuff what do you think and I tried not
to inform him of my perspective so I
don't think there was any risk of
polluting his perspective but there
would be
I wouldn't have to worry about it and he
was very dubious
about shedding now
okay so I went on from that point
thinking yeah there's something weird
about this shedding story it probably is
not a significant thing and I now have
not only the fact that my model says
it's very unlikely the dosage
consideration makes it unlikely but I
also have somebody who knows this topic
from a completely different perspective
who sees it the same way okay
I will say that after that the medical
dissidents
have taken on
increasing seriousness about the
question of shedding is there a shedding
phenomenon so that is to say in spite of
the fact that a standard model of
dosages would suggest this is unlikely
to be significant there is enough
pattern in the universe that causes
people who were initially dubious to
wonder and there are in fact some places
in which shedding is probably a
significant factor things like
breastfeeding
blood transfusions
and potentially sex right right but that
none of those are shedding well they're
shedding but they're not shedding in the
sense of uh yeah I mean it's it's fluid
exchange right exactly fluid exchange is
different from shedding exactly well
it's a subcategory but let's just say
that would make sense if there was some
consideration uh in places where where
fluid is exchanged
um but not in you know
breathing right in the same space as
somebody for example okay so in any case
we've updated our model there are some
special cases which might have an
important relevance and I believe sadly
there is some evidence that suggests
there have been some injuries from this
but then we have a claim like the one in
this tweet now the one in the tweet I
don't want to fault the person who
uh reports this because they are
reporting something factual now I'm in
no position to check their facts but
what they're saying is that there is a
temporal uh a temporal alignment of
their presence with a recently
vaccinated person and then this symptom
showing up which has been shown to be
the product of uh it's an adverse event
that follows mRNA vaccination
so the question is is there something
going on that suggests the model is
incomplete
is this person actually reporting an
adverse event from a inoculation that
they didn't get or not uh two days after
spending time with a friend who would
just receive the vaccine my heart began
to have severe irregularities and it
took me a year to recover
um
well I mean I I
again we don't know this person but I
don't know anything about his life but
um you know pointing pointing to a two
days after and then I've had a year of
sounds like a kind of temporal causality
but it doesn't say anything about all of
the other things that this person was
doing for you know those two days the
seven days before the month before any
of it right like did they did they have
covet right like you know there's all
sorts of things that might have been
true and so you know it's it's it's it's
a very selective story as stories always
are right but uh but but it but it it
certainly doesn't demonstrate anything
with the kind of assurance that the tone
suggests right well this demonstrates
nothing we agree yeah with that the
question is could it be indicative of
something it could is it likely to be
indicative of something I don't think so
now if we go back to the model of
vaccine injury that uh that I presented
the model whereby the transfection of
cells around the body haphazardly
results in the immune system attacking
the cells that are making this foreign
protein because the immune system
effectively assumes that the those cells
have been virally infected and it is
programmed to destroy virally infected
cells
is that likely to be going on here as a
result of shedding and could it be
causing this myocarditis and here's what
I would say and what I said to the the
friend in question
dosage suggests that that is near
impossible
that it is not impossible that a
stabilized mRNA could escape a
vaccinated person be taken in by
breathing or some other mechanism by
somebody who hadn't been vaccinated
could transfect a cell and that that
cell could be destroyed by the immune
system
but the point is the degree of harm that
would come from a small number of these
instances would be so tiny that it would
be undetectable in fact
when a really good vaccine is based on
the technology of attenuation an
attenuated virus vaccine infects cells
and the immune system does kill them
right and the point is there's not a
pathology that comes from a good vaccine
because it's a small number of cells it
may be Millions but uh it's a small
number of cells right there's cell death
and so the point is if you're if you
were able to measure finally enough is
it possible that somebody could shed a
particle that would have this impact on
a cell that would cause the loss of a
heart cell in the worst case yeah but
you wouldn't notice it so I don't think
that myocarditis could be caused by this
could I be wrong absolutely and I will
tell you how I could be wrong on this
but my basic point is if the thing
functions the way we think it does this
story does not function it does not it
is not causally explanatory and
um what I would say is remember I every
time I talk about this topic I say
remember that myoc carditis itis means
inflammation right
the reason that myocarditis is being
caused by these mRNA vaccines we now
effectively know this based on what
we've seen based on what we've showed
last week for example
is that there is damage to the heart
damage done when transfected cells are
attacked by the immune system and
destroyed right it's like a burn inside
the heart or any other tissue and it
will be every other tissue every tissue
that is perfused with blood and takes up
these particles
but
itis is a syndrome it's a symptom it is
not the disease itself but the point is
this person reporting that they had
myocarditis that's not a high degree of
specificity it doesn't say that it's the
same kind of myocarditis it's a symptom
of it's a manifestation now myocarditis
is serious yeah right this person had a
serious something from some cause right
but it is unlikely to be the thing that
causes people who have taken in large
numbers of these mRNA uh particles
to have myocarditis which is to say an
internal burn of of their heart right
now okay so basically the point here is
really about well what do you do with a
model well you've now heard a model
about what these Adverse Events are
that model says that this story about
somebody shedding particles and causing
the same phenomenon in an unvaccinated
person unlikely to be true at least not
by the same mechanism
okay so that's what the model does it
allows you to extrapolate does that give
you certainty absolutely not and then I
would say I would open up another Branch
here and I would say if it turned out
that there was a pattern that people who
had been in proximity to those who had
been transfected without having been
transfected themselves showed this
pattern of damage consistent with having
been transfected
how is that possible right I'm not
saying this is true but what would I
think if I saw that it wasn't one person
reporting this but it was a pattern that
had been consistently demonstrated
then I would have to say well you need
something that would amplify the harm of
a small number of particles right
something akin to a prion disease
so a prion disease is one in which and
by the way there is a whole interesting
topic to be explored as to whether or
not prions are really uh pathogens or
whether they are just a strange kind of
self-propagating error right but put
that aside for a second a prion is a
distinction that you're making here
being that pathogen in your dictionary
that you've just
uh implied uh is benefiting from its
engagement with host whereas some
self-replicating error is just existing
without any
um any any benefit or cost to itself
from its interaction with host yeah so
the really what I'm evoking is there's
an evolutionary phenomenon going on when
you have a prion a prion is a folding of
a protein that is contagious in the
pathogenic case you have a misfolding of
a protein that causes other proteins
with the same sequence to misfold the
same way
um so like mad cow disease
but the question is
is this effectively a kind of life that
doesn't have any uh DNA or RNA in it
that the information is the fold and it
is actually evolving and it's our true
pathogen or is this a kind of Quirk the
way cancer is Right cancers evolve but
most cancers are not contagious and
therefore the fact that you get a cancer
is you know your own systems failure to
control a kind of runaway process it's
not cancer isn't trying to kill you now
there are Cancers it does raise the
question of like what what is different
in those few cancers that are contagious
right right like the the one that
afflicts the Tasmanian devils that's the
only one that I can come up with there
are there are several but there are um
it's definitely as far as we know the
exception and not the rule and the
public health pattern does not reflect
that it's anything other than an
exception so
but anyway point being a contagious
misfolding is the kind of thing that
could take a tiny dose of something and
turn it into a serious problem just the
same way that a virus you may get a tiny
number of particles one of those
particles gets through all of the
defenses and then that particle creates
billions of copies of itself creating a
pathology right the one particle would
be incapable of doing it but the fact
that it copies itself causes these
pathologies so anyway long and short of
it is hey models are cool
you get a model of the Adverse Events
and then you can say well here I'm
hearing a report of an adverse event
does it match the model nope it
certainly would be in conflict with the
model it might need a separate model and
if it needed a separate model it would
have to look like something with an
amplifier in it so let's assume this is
a odd Coincidence of a person who just
happened to get myocarditis from some uh
other influence that temporarily was
unfortunately connected to their
proximity to some transfected person but
should the pattern turn up in a
systematic way that demands an
explanation where to look for
explanations amplifiers
foreign
[Music]